- [Man] Today of all days.
- We need to get
another car, man.
I ain't gonna lie to you,
but I think I'm too cute
to be pushing this shit.
- Mike, if you don't shut
your fat ass up and push.
- I just hope nobody from
the show sees us, that's all.
- Why are you worrying
about people from the show
seeing us, man, we parked
30 miles away, man we good.
- I'm not sure.
- Bullshit, man, did ya'll
even check the alternator?
- [Together] What's
the alternator,
what's it smell like?
- Hey, you're Dorm
Entertainment!
Great show tonight, guys!
- [Together] Hey, how
you doin', what's up man?
- It's actually Dormtainment.
- Is that your car?
- [Together] Yeah.
- Broke as fuck, man. (laughs)
Oh, six guys in
one car. (laughs)
- Shut up, bitch!
(hip hop music)
- Hey, hey some
softy from the show
just slid through
my DMs saying "hey"
- [Together] She trying to fuck.
- Hey, no no no, she just said
"bring one of your friends"
for her roommate.
- Nope.
- Well I know what
you're asking.
- I would, man, but
I got bubble guts.
You don't want me there.
- As you can see, I'm very busy.
- Mike.
- (laughs) You better
get out of my face, dog.
You know I got a girlfriend.
- Mike, please, come on,
Mike, you gotta come with me.
- Nigga you know I love,
we just started
having raw sex, man.
- Mike, I know you
love your girl.
We all love your girl.
- What?
- Listen, I promise you,
just sit on the couch
and ignore the sounds
coming from the other room.
(claps)
Smashing sounds, Mike.
I'm just gonna dip
it in and rip it out.
- Don't ever visualize
that to me again, but okay.
- All right guys, tow
truck is on its way.
- Oh god, thank you.
- But it's gonna
cost another $500.
(they groan and complain)
- Come on man, what the fuck?
- So we've got to gather
up $500 first, so...
- You know, if I hadn't
bought some condoms earlier.
- I got two pennies
in the glove box.
- We can't just use the
check from the show?
- All the banks are
closed right now.
Where we gonna cash it?
- Emmanuel, why
is that an issue?
We in the hood, you
can cash a check
at a children's hospital, my G.
- All right, that's
a good point.
Cam, come with me.
- Why I gotta go?
- Because you've got a
license, I need someone...
- You ashamed of
being in your 20's
and don't have no
license? (laughs)
- No he not.
- Great, Cam, come with me,
the rest of y'all,
stay by the car.
Me and Cam will be back.
(siren sounds in distance)
- Mike, you ready?
- Hey man, I feel like my ass
is about to give
birth to gremlins.
Hey, I gotta shit man, come
on, we gotta get out of here.
- All right.
- It's coming around like
my head is coming out.
- You look a lot different
in your profile picture.
Close enough.
- Gremlins comin
out my ass, oh god.
- Are you stripping
to pay tuition?
Because you look
like a stripper.
- What's up with
the little guy, huh?
What are you smiling
at, little guy?
Turn down for what?